GILBERT STRANG: OK.
Well my problem today
is a little different.
Because I don't have
two initial conditions,
as we normally have for a
second-order differential
equation.
Instead, I have two
boundary conditions.
So let me show you the equation.
So I'm changing t
to x because I'm
thinking of this as a problem
in space rather than in time.
So there's the
second derivative.
The minus sign is
for convenience.
This is the load.
But here's the new thing.
I'm on an interval 0 to 1.
And at 0-- let me take 0 for
the two boundary conditions.
So my solution somehow
does something like this.
Maybe up and back down.
So it's 0 there, 0
there, and in between it
solves the
differential equation.
Not a big difference,
but you'll see
that it's an entirely
new type of problem.
OK.
As far as the solution
to the equation goes,
there is nothing enormously new.
I still have a y particular.
A particular solution
that solves the equation.
And then I still have the y
null, the homogeneous solution,
any solution that solves
the equation with 0
on the right hand side.
And in this example--
this is especially
simple-- the null equation would
be second derivative equal 0.
And those are the
functions, linear functions,
that have second
derivative equal zero.
So there's the general solution.
And now I have to put in,
not the initial conditions,
but the boundary conditions.
OK.
So I substitute x equal 0.
And I substitute x
equal 1 into this.
I have to find y particular.
I'll do two examples.
But the general
principle is to get
these numbers, these
constants like C1 and C2,
from the boundary conditions.
I'll put in x equal zero.
And then I'll have y of 0,
which is y particular at 0,
still defined, plus
C times 0, plus d.
That's the solution at the left
end, which is supposed to be 0.
And then at the
right end, end, I
have whatever this
particular solution is at 1,
plus now I'm putting
in x equal 1.
I'm just plugging in x
equals 0, and then x equal 1.
And x equal 1, I have C plus D.
C plus D. And that gives me 0.
The two 0's come
from there and there.
OK.
Two equations.
They give me C and
D. So I'm all solved.
Once I know how-- I
know how to proceed once
I find a particular solution.
So I'll just do two examples.
They'll have two
particular solutions.
And they are the most important
examples in applications.
So let me start with
the first example.
So my first example is going
to be the equation minus D
second y, Dx squared, equal 1.
That will be my load.
f of x is going to be 1.
So I'm looking for a particular
solution to that equation.
And of course I
can find a function
whose second derivative
is 1, or maybe minus 1.
My function will be-- well, if
I want the second derivative
to be 1, then probably 1/2 x
squared is the right thing.
And that would give me a minus.
So I think I have a
minus 1/2 x squared.
That solves the equation.
And now I have the Cx
plus D. The homogeneous,
the null solution.
And now I plug in.
And again, I'm always
taking y of 0 to be 0,
and also y of 1 to be 0.
Boundary conditions.
Again, boundary condition,
not initial condition.
OK.
Plug in x equal 0.
At x equals 0, what do I learn?
x equal 0.
That's 0, that's 0, so
I learn that D is 0.
At x equal 1, what do I learn?
This is minus 1/2.
D is 0 now.
And x is 1.
So I think we learn
C is plus 1/2.
OK with that?
At x equal 1, I'm
supposed to get 0
from the boundary condition.
So I have minus 1/2,
plus 1/2, plus 0.
I do get 0.
This is good.
So this answer is-- Cx, then,
is 1/2 x minus 1/2 x squared.
That's it.
That's my solution.
That function is 0 at both ends,
and it solves the differential
equation.
So that's a simple example.
And maybe I can give
you an application.
Suppose I have a rod.
Here's a bar.
And those lines that I
put at the top and bottom
are the ones that give me
the boundary conditions.
And I have a weight.
A weight of 1.
Maybe the bar itself.
It gives-- elastic force.
Gravity will pull,
displace, the bar downwards
because of its weight.
It's elastic.
And this function
gives me the solution,
gives me the distribution.
If I go down a distance
x, then that tells me
that this part of the
bar, originally at x,
will move down by
an additional y.
Moves.
So this is now at x plus y of x.
And that's the y.
And that is 0 at the
bottom, 0 at the top,
and positive in between.
OK.
That was a pretty quick
description of an application.
And more important, a pretty
quick solution to the problem.
Can I do a second example
that won't be quite as easy?
OK.
So again, my equation
is going to be
minus the second
derivative equals a load.
But now it will be a point load.
A point load.
That's a point
load at x equal A.
This is my friend,
the delta function.
The delta function,
you remember,
is 0, except at that one
point where this is 0.
This is 0 at the
point x equal A.
In my little picture
of a physical problem,
now I don't have any
weight in the bar.
The bar is thin.
Weightless.
But I'm putting on, at the point
x equal A, right at this point,
I'm attaching a weight.
So this distance is x equal
A. Here's my weight, my load,
hanging at this point.
So I can see what will happen.
That load hanging
down there will
stretch the part above
the bar, above the load,
and compress the
part below the load.
So it's a point load.
Very important application.
OK.
Now I have this
equation to solve.
OK.
I can solve it on the
one side of A, x equal A.
And I can solve it
on the other side
of x equal A. Let me do that.
For x less than A, I have
minus the second derivative.
And what's the delta
function for x below A,
on the left side of the spike?
0.
And x on the right side
of the load, again, 0.
And what are the solutions
to the null equation?
y is Cx plus D on the left
side of the load, there.
And now here it may have
some different constants.
y equals, what shall
I say, E x plus F,
on the right side of the load.
And now I've got
four numbers to find.
C, D, E, and F.
And what do I know?
I know two boundary conditions.
Always I know that y of 0 is 0,
from fixing the top of the bar.
So y of 0 equal 0.
And when I put in x equal
0, that will tell me D is 0.
And then also y of 1 is 0.
And that will be on
this side of the load.
So when I put in x equal 1, that
will tell me that E plus F is
0, at x equal 1.
So it tells me that
F is minus E, right?
So what do I know now?
D is gone.
0.
F is minus E. So can I just
change this to F is minus E.
So I had E x minus
E. E times x minus 1
takes care of that
boundary condition.
At x equal 1, it's gone.
OK.
But I still have two,
C and E, to find.
So what are my two further
conditions at the jump?
So far I'm on the left of the
jump, the spike, the impulse,
the delta function.
And on the right of it.
But now I've got to say, what's
happening at the impulse?
At the delta function.
Or at the point load.
OK.
Well, what's happening there?
I need two equations.
I've still got C and E to find.
So my first equation
is that at that load,
the bar is not going
to break apart.
It's just going to be stretched
above and compressed below.
But it is not going
to break apart.
So at the load, at
which is x equal A.
So now I'm ready for x equal A.
OK.
What happens at x equal A?
That's the same as that.
Let me draw a picture
of the solution, here.
Here is x.
This is x.
Here's y.
Here is x equal 0.
Here is x equal 1.
I see a linear function.
Cx up to the point
x equal A. And here
I have a linear function
coming back to 0.
You see?
That's the picture
of the solution.
The graph of the solution.
It has this 0 at
the left boundary.
It has 0 at the right boundary.
It has, in between, it
is Cx in the x minus E.
And I have made it
continuous at x equal A.
The bar is not coming apart.
So that this solution
runs into that solution.
That's good.
That's one more condition.
But I need one further,
one final, condition.
And somehow I have to
use the delta function.
And what does the
delta function tell me?
I'm just going to go give you
the answer here, rather than
a theory of delta functions.
That equation.
So you see what my solution is.
It's a broken line
with a change of slope.
It's a ramp.
It has a corner.
All those words describe
functions like this.
So I have some slope going
up here, and some slope--
and let me tell you.
I'll tell you what
those slopes are.
I'll tell you what those
slopes are in this.
So I'll tell you the answer
and then we'll check.
So that C turns out to be 1
minus A. So in this region,
I have 1 minus A times x.
In that region.
And in this region, below,
so that's stretching.
The fact that it's
positive displacement
means it's stretching.
Now this part is going
to be in compression,
with that negative slope.
And I think in this region
it's 1 minus x times A, which
will be coming from there.
So there is my solution.
Because of the delta function,
I need a two part solution.
To the left of the delta
function, the point load.
And to the right
of the point load.
And then we could
check that at the load,
x equal A. This is
1 minus A times A.
This is 1 minus A
times A. They do meet.
And now comes this
mysterious fourth condition
about the slopes.
The slope drops by 1.
Here the slope is
1 minus A. That's
1 minus A is the slope there.
And here the slope is minus
A. You see minus x times A,
so the derivative is minus A.
So it was 1 minus A. The
1 dropped away and left me
with minus A. That's what
the solution looks like.
And now I have to say
one word about why
did the slope drop by 1.
The slope dropped by 1,
from 1 minus A to minus A.
And that has to come
from this delta function.
And of course you remember
about the delta function.
The key point is if when you
integrate the delta function,
you get 1.
So when I integrate
this equation, I get a 1
on the right hand
side from the delta.
And on the left hand
side, I'm integrating
the second derivative, so
I get the first derivative.
Great.
The first derivative
at the end point,
minus the first derivative
at the start point,
should be the 1.
And that's the drop of 1.
I'll do a full-scale
job with delta functions
in another video.
I want to keep this
one under control.
We're seeing the new idea
is boundary conditions,
and here we're seeing a
delta function equation
in this boundary value problem.
Thank you.